hey this is presh talwalkar
triangle abc is an isosceles triangle
with a b equal to ac and angle a equal
to 100 degrees
extend the side a b as shown to the
point d
in such a way that a d is equal to bc
then construct dc
the question is what is the measure of
angle b d c
i thank druba jyoti from india for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
this is a tricky problem and i admit i
was not able to solve it
there are many ways to solve the problem
but i'm going to share one solution that
i found particularly fascinating
focus on triangle
since this is an isosceles triangle with
a vertex angle equal to 100 the other
two angles will be equal to 40 degrees
each
since ad is equal to bc
we can translate and rotate triangle abc
in such a way that bc will overlap a d
now let's label the image of a as a
prime
since this triangle is congruent to
triangle abc
we'll have a prime is equal to 100
degrees and each of the other two angles
is equal to 40 degrees
so that means this angle is equal to 40
degrees leaving 60 degrees from the 100
and the angle bda prime is equal to 40
degrees
we also have that a prime d is equal to
a prime a
from here construct a prime c
now triangle aca prime is an isosceles
triangle with a vertex angle equal to 60
degrees
so aca prime is an equilateral triangle
all three of its angles will be equal to
60 degrees and all three sides will be
equal to each other
from here
let's focus on triangle c a prime d
c a prime is equal to a prime d so we
have an isosceles triangle and its
vertex angle is equal to 160 degrees so
each of the other two angles will be
equal to 10 degrees each
in particular a prime dc is equal to 10
degrees
we can then subtract the measure of
angle a prime dc
from the measure of angle bda prime
to get that angle bdc is equal to 40
minus 10 which is equal to 30 degrees
and that's the answer
what an interesting geometry question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you